even Tyler Perry movies are getting
indulgent on the logo lengths do you
think I need to see all the other Madea
movies in order to understand this one
also how generic is this title a Madea
Halloween that's just a person in a
calendar date true I've never been in a
friend but is it common for a dozen frat
brothers to pack into a room randomly
and wait just so they can be addressed
when the president comes out the stairs
also judging by the stairs you've
already decorated for this year's
Halloween party so at least half the
work is done
no so we're throwing any kind of acting
subtlety out the window right from the
start then okay good to know here's 30
sins to pay your ham tax through the
rest of the movie
you mean that digital sex crime I do
remember that and no one even got
arrested somehow very fun still
harassment and more importantly he's
still not funny apparently parkour is
now a prerequisite for joining a frat
I'm Ronaldo when my friends call me
hoarse subtle you are now staring at you
salon Thetas finest worst stop routine
ever no go College right so y'all
probably never seen it do before in real
life this is like a key and Peele sketch
that was cut for being more reality than
it was funny this right here this is
what a dude looks like no this is what
an over actor who probably won't get
another job looks like first you second
he wrote this line about himself he
scripted a teenage girl declaring his
own character hot please zero story
purpose this literally is never
referenced again ring the shame bell
Tyler ring it hurt Old Man River ain't
you got some pigeons two feet of
something Old Man River pigeons did he's
time travel from the 20s what the hell
leads helluva kill op tops in some
misguided Eddie Murphy tribute that's
gone for way too long this is just the
first of many characters Tyler Perry
himself will play in this movie these
girls walk past Greek house after Greek
house and some kind of throwback to the
days when land wasn't so valued and
developers and the university itself had
already snatched up half the land here
for themselves oh my god Slenderman wait
did that hi-5 routine include a double
boob grab I'm getting more and more
creeped out thinking about Tyler Perry
writing these things does he think this
is how teenage girls really interact
wait they scampered off screen before we
went to a wide shot I think not but hey
editors got to edit you know no way
we're staying so call her dad ladies and
gentlemen parenting they like us they
actually don't okay leaving your iPad
out in the open and messaging about your
lame dad before your lame dad is left
how stupid is this girl anyway Tyler
Perry ladies and gentlemen in his second
role in this film please give it up for
discount Eddie Murphy y'all Madea was
terrible at trick-or-treating also Jesus
pumpkin Jesus and right next to a wee
pumpkin maybe what is hope oh one cake
well technically the joke is Horo one
case cuz you know horror rhymes with
four but apparently that's too racy for
this film how is ho any more appropriate
also I know this movie wasn't made for
me but couldn't it at least have been
made with a little tiny bit of quality
this King seen this discount over long
SNL reject sketch of a scene goes on for
some time big about to shoot to to pop
this is the second week Biggie joke
inside sixty Seconds all because this
kid is conversation between the movie
and me ends up in the script over seven
minutes of the show I'm not even lying
that's racist walk it off I swear
without characters repeating each other
this movie would be shorter than burnt
Rory you know you scored let p.m. time
get scared they've made eight of these
movies there are as many Madea movies as
Star Wars films damn it I think I just
gave them an idea for another one blow
my daddy
bitch yet another character played by
Tyler Perry and if you haven't realized
at this point the Tyler Perry is
basically pissed at SNL for not hiring
him now you know
casual sexual harassment she says you
get to drop one say prostate other sake
careful prostate calendar you know
everyone says these movies are the
modern Ernest movies but I must have
forgotten the prostate cancer joke and
Ernest scared stupid Tyler Perry makes
jim Varney look like Laurence Olivier
imma give you a prostate exam but it's
right there funny different ways can I
come up with to say something in this
movie isn't funny now we're gonna find
out I think
Madea says what people have been saying
to Tyler Perry for years so at 15 she
was stripping at frat parties and this
movie thinks that's not only not
offensive but hilarious do I have that
right
I feel like this movie just thinks
anything Madea says is hilarious this
goes on for some time support situation
who's probably I belong to I'm going to
send this line first and foremost for
terrible grammar and not making sense
also I'm gonna send the casual
hospitalization after child abuse
I bet audiences work up falling right
out of their seats at the hilarious
beating in the four-year-old
jesus-fuckin'-christ pocket your pencil
went straight to one his lip balm dad
throws kid off Rufus punishment kid
loses a testicle but it's funny because
of how it's being described right now by
a dude in drag also this movie man it's
like the Nutty Professor meets scary
movie with the budget of girl fight can
you please not tell her that I asked you
to come by we are just now getting to
the point of this scene ten full minutes
of this unfunny sexist homophobic
physically abusive but it's cute because
they're old people nonsense just to
finally get back to the actual plot I
want out can someone grab madea's hammer
just one swing right here I need to rest
so far this movie is literally two
scenes of people saying horrific they
think it's funny I haven't seen the
other Madea movies but it's obvious they
stopped trying long before this one if
you're the kind of person that hangs
lights for Halloween you are definitely
doing it better than this this teenage
girl has a blown-up photo of a Ken dolls
face on a wall like he's Davey fucking
Jones
sit we're gonna trick them into going to
bed early acting ladies and gentlemen
look what I brought home from school
school send home board games this card
comes from mr. Wilson the men that died
in this house on Halloween this may be
the earliest into a movie that I've
wanted to punch Chris in the face she
gave this clicker to her friend and told
her to wait for the signal but she never
told her to make the lights flash on and
off and she could easily have just had
that clicker in our own damn hand
without it being detected this is not
what the bed looked like when they were
done staging it frat party is literally
around the corner as Brian said earlier
Madea decides to drive there zboob jeez
is every single character in this a
walking stereotype movie stereotypes
harder than Don Rickles behold paradise
right before your eyes popular comment
from Bella Thorne's Instagram followers
somehow makes its way into the script
this movie wants to have its sexual
harassment is funny sometimes but other
times offensive cake and eat it too
spit it up for Tiger movie thinks gettin
Tiger to cameo is a good get but movie
doesn't realize what a joke it is so I
don't like this well I like this I don't
I don't like this my thoughts exactly
every piece of audio for this goddamn
taiga concert was plugged into a single
fucking electrical outlet
self-respecting frat has a goddamn
electronic dartboard pussies after
literally getting tossed out of the
party a madea and her friends just give
up and this should be the end of the
movie that should never have even been
made but it's not we're only halfway
through folks are you 17 no we can all
get kicked out of school for this for
what you haven't done anything with her
legal drinking age is 21 so you're
basically talking about the sex here you
haven't done any of it also thanks to
the fourth Transformers movie I know
that many states have unique age of
consent laws and depending on the state
and fall 17 might not be illegal though
I don't know the guy's age and that's
part of the equation mostly if this
movie for making me think more about
statutory rape laws than transformers
for what the party getting shut down are
you leaving your own frat house before
complaining about the party being shut
down you can live here bro oh we're
gonna get so leaving fellas here's the
plan thankfully there are no party
busting cops with an ear shot of this
conspiratorial conversation but a day is
here eavesdropping in the single worst
hiding spot I've ever seen in my life
stupid add a pop quiz hotshot these
knocks lead to two full minutes of
arguing over who will answer the door a
white people joke absolutely zero laughs
ollie above
if you said D you win nothing no one
wins anything today she even looked at
the door once this entire scene things
are gonna get around here she's saying
this but the party she wants to sneak
back out to has literally been shut down
by the cops and she knows it so what's
going on party is done but she's still
going through with the scare the
relatives plan for no reason whatever
both explanation they end up using for
how this was done in the real world is
bull whatever goes creeper killer thing
this movie is going for waste tons of
time making an old lady turn her TV back
off for some reason yes Lord after
everything she's been through tonight
she thinks this is god movie implies
that these frat bros with IQs that max
out at room temperature could edit
together this video in less than 15
minutes even as an older person she
moves pretty
despite falling down watch out they hurt
noises more importantly why did you go
to bed in the evening dress with full
jewelry in a purse
ain't no playing no damn jokes I'm
playing with myself Tyler Perry's
writing motto hey I'm tired brother down
the stairs
Sam's out of shape well the movie has
played fast and loose with her need for
double walking canes but even if she's
faking the cane need she's clearly old
and frail hold up dammit check and see
pussy man bitch please dude is still
jerking off while having this
conversation
I take all you holds the hotel if your
holes don't pay it's times like these I
try not to think about the fact that
this movie made more at the box office
than moonlight captain fantastic age of
17 and hell or high water combined this
movie is only a movie and not a short
sketch because of extended bolt like
this how did the clown not see this
coming
Madea survives this how did this clown
even get here I mean even if Madea is
death her friends would have been
looking straight at it penny wise but
penny ain't that wise all these
guardians run leave him behind a couple
teenagers and a horny old bastard to be
devoured by the evil clown Madea equals
selfish too late to be asking this
suddenly immoral lady reason 22 why this
is a feature film instead of a single
man TV sketch this car breakdown leads
to a two full minutes of arguing over
how to fix the car be a women don't know
cars joke see absolutely zero laughs or
deep why the hell am I still watching
this freakin movie please make it stop
already how did they get so far out into
the woods e wilderness after just
leaving the house how did these guys
even get out here and how did they know
that the car would break down here and
how did they bring their own lighting
and ground fog effects is this
fraternity also a traveling theater
troupe look at all the zombies come from
I might been watching the same movie I
was 20 minutes ago
settle down jerk de soleil we get it
you're a flippin zombie this zombie over
her shoulder is auditioning for the
opening scene of lala land
not acting in this movie currently being
filmed to do back in the day baby was no
fun BAM
this made 70 million dollars baby you
got to give like Joel Osteen Joel Osteen
jokes understood by and funny too
exactly no one they hacked into the TV
the lights the plumbing happened to the
plumbing the plumbing I don't care if
you're one of the brothers Mario
plumbing is not hackable and when you
were in the car and the zombies came out
of the woods how does he know this
happen she hasn't mentioned it and even
if a day heard them planning it that
doesn't mean they follow through yet he
says it like he knows it for a fact once
in for trying to bind my cussing fudgey
movie wait what the helmets cheese and
rice it worked you trying to tell me
right now that that was that is there
some pastoral rule about only conveying
important information in person you were
just on the phone with her also why
would you even call it a church when
apparently there is a service going on
um Ronaldo but everybody calls me hoarse
that's it I've had enough of this hoary
horny Halloween I was gonna let these
lame sex jokes lot because it's a comedy
but dang right it that was every forking
person in this movie such a sex at it
here's a sin for this one and 20 more to
cover the rest of this pervy parade
retro actively calling the homeowner to
try and sort out a hauntings
authenticity I told you not to go so I
did get over it fracking teenagers man
entitled Sun's up which is weight
snatcher up by her new growth do I want
to know what new growth means son of a
biscuit this movie is the worst
yes we've sworn plenty in this video
already but just go with the motif and
try not to worry about it what is wrong
with you all people
bratty teenage daughter would be
excellent at cinema sins oh so her
having an affair in this house isn't her
running over you whoa we're in the hello
dolly did that come from that's what
this movie is about movie thinks it can
do ninety minutes straight of age race
sex boob jokes and still somehow land an
emotional ending in the last 10 minutes
okay
to be a joke nope no jokes around here
at least not funny ones you have to
abide by the rules in this house if I
say it you have to abide by do you
understand what about when you say go
Bama or something like Trump was right
about that one thing even then thank you
eyes more not funny from the not funny
side character color me bored after
seeing a dead girl all these frat bros
collectively decide to bail and keep
quiet and that's morally reprehensible
Jesus how elaborate is this prank the
entire police force is in on it
they brought a mix Jenner prison bus and
stocked it with people who are supposed
to be what other prisoners so they just
drove the prisoners around and make new
arrests this prank is simultaneously the
most intricate and ignorant prank of all
time let's see which type of sex joke
haven't we told yet prison sex
Yahtzee a day's death with fate as was
the concept that any of this film's main
characters would actually be taken off
on a prison bus you get off the bus and
you get off the bus and you wait she did
that herself
maybe the movie should have hired her to
make Tyler Perry's old people cloths
look a little less like they were
designed at all a petit de Leatherface
what I am what I am what I am I will
hide the weasel path the prophets bit of
the old Humpty Dumpty like a little
sister roll along the girls come out at
midnight at midnight I blow you all up
I'm just 17 I am 16 going on 17 may the
wisdom pleading you know meet with are
far sorry